women face a variety of pitfalls there
the stylistic pitfalls you know how do I
present myself how do I do that because
women tend to be I think more
emotionally aware and commotions
conversation with themselves than men
how do i how do i navigate my own
presence with others in the world of
business and how do i do that in a way
that feels like it is you know authentic
for me true to me I think that's that's
a real challenge I think there are
enormous small everyday practical
challenges I'm still struck by them and
I've been in working with business
people for for 20 20 almost 25 years and
with male more predominately male
business people and I'll just give you a
couple of examples that every woman
that's you know it's you know digging
around on big thankful we're late til
one is that I still can't sit in the
meeting with with with men and not have
someone pick up an idea that I've
ventured earlier in the meeting and say
hey I've got a great idea and every
woman I know talks about this women tend
to have a more difficult time at the
table all decibel levels being equal
being heard they tend to get interrupted
more off and they tend to be asked to do
things and this is a whole levels this
is an all levels perhaps we kept the
very very top of a big organization they
tend to be asked to you know get coffee
or Xerox or you know make you know
fulfill an important administrative task
before men do and really in ways that
aren't really appropriate for the for
the content and the caliber of the
meeting so there are lots and lots of
daily just logistical challenges I think
there's a very important emotional and
and you know mental challenge and that
is that if you think about the broad
landscape of American business there
aren't that many women right out there
on the stage talking on a regular basis
there are a few you know terrific women
you know you know that are prominent I
think of Patti sellers at fortune or and
more of time you know Andrew Young and
Yvonne you
Indira Nui at Pepsi so there are there
are a handful maybe two fistfuls full of
really prominent top-notch women out
there but there probably aren't very
many more than that at least that we get
regular access to through the media or
that we have personal access to and so I
think the issue of role models right
interact distant even mentors is a huge
issue for women starting their own
businesses or climbing the the the
ladder of business you know I know at
the Harvard Business School I have women
stream through my office in my second
year MBA class talking about their
search for women role models or women
that they can learn from even indirectly
and so I think that piece is a very very
big deal and I think finally there's an
issue of what does it mean to be a woman
you know that's very very ambitious in
the business world and that you know
that bumps up against these other issues
of stereotypes and and you know
emotional pitfalls but but that question
is really not very well defined in our
society right now I mean there aren't
even you know a small array of good
answers to that question and there's a
lot of still unspoken and more and more
verbal discomfort by lots of different
people about powerful women in business
at any level so so it's interesting to
see what their end result in mine from
my experience is of all these different
kinds of pitfalls and what and what I
see in the very near term for women in
business I what I see is that a lot of
very successful women end up starting
their own businesses and and guess what
they often hire and mentor and nurture a
lot of other women they create their
village right they create their pride of
elephants if you will and they take
their power and they go and they laugh
and they put their lipstick on at the
end of meetings and they claim you know
financial gain and market market
influence and they do it with great
aplomb and freedom and so I think we'll
see more and more of that you see at the
very small level just need to spend a
little bit of time and you know any
local Chamber of Commerce to see women
running their own businesses with lots
of other women and lots of working
mothers doing this because it gives them
freedom but I think we're going to see
that more and more in terms of
businesses that emerge onto the national
stage or businesses that emerge into a
very powerful position and and then I
think when that is ready to give way in
the world is ready to integrate yet a
little more will have a more textured
tapestry of women at the top of
companies
so I I don't I like to say that I don't
believe or I don't hold up put much
credence and work-life balance I think
we have one line for many many women and
men work is very important important
part of that I think for most people
work and how it makes us feel and what
it provides for us and how it allows us
or doesn't allow us to realize our
dreams is very very significant and so I
think we need a recasting of the issue
of work in its place I think we need to
take our cues if you will from perhaps
from the iPod shuffle and from the
incredible way in which our days our
music our minds our computers our
shopping our working habits our eating
habits and the way in which we're mixing
and matching so many things and all
these new playlists we're moving from
one thing to the next right we read this
and then go over to read this we did use
this file then we use this file we shop
at this store for this and in a very
different store for something else we
mix and match and we and I think that is
what's really happening to our work what
and this is happening in many many
different kinds of of work not just a
very specific kind of symbolic analysts
pursuits it's happening all over the
place not only because of new
flexibility and downsizing in corporate
America but just because of what people
are demanding in the way our lives are
living so I think we're gonna see a lot
more mixing and matching and cutting and
pasting and again the kind of bellwether
of that ISM are the Millennials who
whatever they're doing are not doing it
nine-to-five and sitting in you know and
sitting in them and sitting in an office
and they're not doing it the way many
people of my generation doing it which
is we're just tied and tethered and
married to our Blackberry or our
smartphone they're really you know
intermixing skateboarding and writing a
brief or you know working for one of
their favorite charities and then
running into the office to get something
done so I think we're gonna see a lot
more of that and it's going to be less
about balance and more about doing what
makes us feel a lot
and like we're playing to our stronger
selves in a variety of new ways the
second I think big if you will file
folder for me around work in life is
that in the 12 years since perhaps 14
years since email really started
diffusing rapidly around businesses and
eventually right into the homes and
right into our laps in our PDAs or our
smartphones in those 14 years technology
has has really carried all the power
chips technology really owns us we react
to our BlackBerry's we react to our
inboxes we react to the vibrating phone
we react to it
it is now driving a huge amount of how
millions perhaps billions of people
spend their time day-to-day it's driving
that at home it's driving that work it's
driving that in the car sometimes
driving us to distraction it's
everywhere and it it mostly owns us so
I'm looking forward as a historian to
the moment to the moment when that
balance if you will here's where balance
matters when the scales of power between
technology and its users shift and we
start really thinking about how to use
technology for something other than just
plowing through our inboxes or hitting
reply all we're not there yet
it's coming but it's going to take again
some imagination and some willingness to
have a different perspective than just
oh my god I need to respond right now to
this this jingle or this phone ringing
or this email with a red arrow in the
left-hand corner so so stay tuned
there's a lot of amazing things that can
happen when we reclaim the night take
back the technology night